Hãy like trong bách nhà chỉ sown met, gà sinh nghệ ăn kể chỉ em sần 10%
Nếu tui chân, sinh năm 2, nguyên và đyc nước ai sinh năm 2020, cũng sinh ra và đế lấy được thành phố Vinh,
Nguyên Anh, 2 nhà các nhà còn sau kilomét, nhìn mẹ thi vô nhà các nhà chỉ sown mới cho khu đối đi, họ mới có suy nhất nặp cửa.
Chẳng kỳ, tôi có đyc ai biết nhà qua phy bục, những trở từng nói chuyện, một lần chú đối vị thì công dẫn chàng và nhà đích ai để xem bảo tích kỳ,
nhà của đyc ai khi ai vừa hành tịt phần thô, đón lần đự tiêm học khọt mặt nhau.
Trời hẹp đời, chú đối vị thì công đã đứng xa mai mối, chân xem bê là một sinh đặc biệt,
bôi khoảng cách dã hai nhà có gần, họ năng tinh cho chuyện với nhau hiểu hơn, anh nghĩ cơ thọt mình theo kiểu mình nhăng, thẳng nhăng.
Nguyên ta bảo, nhất cửa li như tục độ, anh nghĩ có cả hai bên trực tình của tựng mình tình trên nặng.
Quân nhau bàn ngày anh ấy đã tỏ tiền, mình trở vì thế trên quá.
Hôm thời gian sau thị được sự thật thả trên thành của anh, mình mới đồng ý, chẳng kể.
Thưa ra mới quên, đất cảnh cho tại sế dế của tư trang, công một đi đâu em cũng chỉ khó đưa đón.
Một lần trang bị ổng, suốt không thể là xem đường dài, đất cảnh vận sản sản chữa câu tương nghi ăn giã hành lỗi khám bệnh.
Hãy bên gia đình để tập lựa yêu nhau thì vực xa mặt, mở hỏi em không có con giấu con giề gần nhà.
Quới thằng bố nâng anh không trong hai người tư sau hồn tháng quên biết, các đời tất cả định về chung mỗi nhà,
và tháng sau đó đam quế của họ được tất cả chức linh đình trong sự chung phục của cả hai người xa đình.
Con bà, bà tích lấy chung gần hay sao?